dr helen sharp
max goodwin how can i help no you're too
kind welcome to the dam
why are you in scrubs uh because i'm a
doctor going somewhere i have to take
segments with the morning show and megan
kelly then give the keynote address at
the oncology conference in vail i'll
take that for you thank you wow you're
gonna do all that on your lunch break
you're funny i'll be back next week your
lunch at the tavern my treat unlike the
previous medical director i actually
expect you to practice medicine at this
hospital because
i don't know it's your job
you're funny
you said that
i'll tell you what i'll continue giving
speeches all over the world because you
can't afford the kind of publicity i
give this hospital
and i'll continue my on-air appearances
with ellen oprah and anyone else
powerful enough to go by one name
because someone has to remind new york
that even though new amsterdam is an
underfunded public hospital we can still
go toe-to-toe with the privates from
basic care to state-of-the-art
procedures i will be back next week will
lunch at the tavern my treat
[Music]
i like her
if she comes back let's keep her
hey i'm just fine she's totally healthy
turns out i was the one who
needed a little help
did you get it
yeah
i think so
oh and i heard my no screens idea went
down without a hitch indeed
smooth as silk good best ideas usually
are
good night
i'm kidding it's a joke it was a
disaster
i heard it was horrible
i know
i know everything that you did i know
that my ideas only work because of you
and so i just wanted to say no
no no you were gonna thank me right i
was good no
because i'm gonna thank you
oh why
i finally felt what you must feel every
time you turn this hospital on its head
and it is quite the rush it is thrilling
and i want more of it i want it every
day
but max i have been your safety net for
so long if i go down this road i am
going to need you to start being mine
[Music]
you look how i feel
you first
so
i'm gonna tell you something
and i need you to not react like max the
revolutionary
which max do you need
the same medical director you really
want me to pick a lane today did
something happen at deposition prep
i don't know i
started to wonder if maybe i'm
doing this wrong
so in what room
i wear these scrubs so i can
actually help
people but what if i'm not helping
what if i'm just making things
worse
i mean maybe i should just wear a suit
you know and actually
sit at my desk like a
sane medical director
[Music]
maybe it's time i stopped trying to be
all things to all people
[Music]
the max who is all things to all people
is the max that we all need
i need
how can i help
okay what was that that's exactly what
you saw
what i saw was pure theatrics max i
handled the situation i can see that but
what exactly is this situation well
let's just say that
castro hasn't changed since i fired her
the last time she is a very talented
doctor but she's always gonna let
ambition get in her way then why did you
bring her back why did you give her half
your department
you have a good night max
i want to know i think you already do
just tell me
for god's sake max
i did it for you
[Music]
everything i have done
i have done for you
[Music]
[Music]
uh helen uh oh hi
okay uh i just thought you should know
that the board is blocking my attempts
to change new amsterdam's name to lenape
hawking shocking i know i think i'm
saying it right it's it's like a hawk a
lenape hawking the guy you were dating
mina that is completely inappropriate oh
no that that's fine because we're not
dating so you know i mean we never did
it uh we just um have spent time
together we spent time together from uh
time to time you know as people do and i
think that uh other people get ideas and
they talk and yeah shut up idiot sorry
real quick did you say
we're dating does that mean you and
cassian are not dating now are you
you might be right this may actually be
hell nice meeting you
i'm sorry about cassio
i don't know what to
say i mean we never talk about it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
i'm really glad that we're friends
[Music]
max
max you need to get out there i
like yeah i i
i let go of this the whole tank's gonna
give it'll go all over the hospital
hundreds of people are gonna be exposed
you need to go get help no
you're gonna leave
i'm gonna hold the pipe and you're gonna
go and get help i can't why not
give me your hand
[Music]
nothing's worked
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right
well here i am
night
you said that
[Music]
you
are
gone
[Music]
this may be hard to hear
but i crave your company
[Music]
we haven't spoken in years
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you